hey guys I'm just McDonald it is the
third of April and us change into games
but news first up let's get this 1080p
sup out of the way so I can cross it off
you guys can get more informed and we
all go home a little more knowledgeable
and a tad grouchy the guy we heard from
yesterday Xbox co-creator ed fries whose
name is actually pronounced at fries
which is much less entertaining has
commented on the xbox one's 1080p
controversy he said that from his
understanding microsoft reserved some of
the consoles power for the operating
system and promised debs they get to use
that spare power eventually but that
never happened as for some more
commentary oddworld creator Lorne
Lanning who mouthed off overheating EA
the other day has said the performance
gap between the xbox one and the ps4 is
closing keep with the change down to the
fact that Deb's are growing accustomed
to the Xbox one and its development
architecture whilst Microsoft are
consistently improving the tool set and
development environment as far as
competitor learning said I have to say
the PlayStation 4 has been pretty
amazing and that's where we've been
spending a lot about time but I don't
see a huge gap like they used to be now
for things that are happening in
Nintendo land that's the land of
Nintendo and not the video game
apparently thanks to the power of the
wii u mario kart 8 is set to be a pretty
visually impressive game the game
designers have said that since it's been
six years since the last mario kart game
and they're working with HD for the
first time they've been able to put a
lot of effort into making this
installment what they're calling a very
pretty game not only that but it's
supposed to be a smooth ride on the
technical side to pun totally intended
last up it's sounding like the upcoming
Star Wars game from visceral games could
be really really cool former uncharted
creative director Amy Hennig has joined
EA to fill the role of creative director
on the new installment the title is
rumored to be open world that we haven't
had any solid confirmation on that just
yet here currently have a deal with
Disney to be the exclusive creator of
Star Wars games for the next ten years
so if you're crazy about the franchise
you'll want to keep an eye on this one
in addition to dices star wars
battlefront let me know in the comments
or on
my Twitter what genre of star wars game
you would like to see hit the market
that is all the good stuff that I've got
for you today but do join me again same
time tomorrow while bringing my top 5
favorite game stories of the whole week
I will see you then